Everyone is up in arms about Ebola, but what
about the Enterovirus?
Is that an even bigger threat to our nation’s
health?
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and there’s
been a lot of media coverage lately about
all kinds of diseases - Ebola, the flu, and
now Enterovirus.
A 4-year-old boy in New Jersey died in his
sleep two weeks ago, making it the first reported
case of death caused by Enterovirus EV-D68.
So what is the Enterovirus, and should we
be worried about it?
/Well, believe it or not, Enterovirus EV-D68
is just one of over 100 different strains
of enterovirus, the most famous one being
poliovirus.
/According to the CDC, the US sees about 10-15
million cases of enterovirus every year, usually
peaking around the end of summer and early
fall.
The EV-D68 strain, though, is a relatively
uncommon form.
Over the past 50 years, it’s been responsible
for fewer than 100 cases of enterovirus.
/So the reason it’s receiving so much attention
THIS year - is because of the sheer amount
of cases of it, and the numbers of hospitalizations
it’s caused.
So far, more than 43 states have reported
cases of the D68 virus.
/Symptoms of enterovirus usually appear in
the form of a bad summer cold - fever, runny
nose, cough, and muscle aches are all indications
of a mild infection.
But D68 in particular, has been linked to
severe respiratory illness, and in some cases,
even temporary paralysis.
Children - and especially those with asthma
- are particularly vulnerable, because they
haven’t been exposed to the virus as much,
and thus haven’t developed an immunity to
it.
Most of them also attend schools, which is
a very easy way to pass the virus around.
/Unfortunately, since there’s really no
cure or vaccine for D68 - the best method
of treatment is prevention.
The CDC is recommending that everyone reduce
their exposure by washing their hands with
soap and water for 20 seconds, keeping their
hands away from their face, and avoiding people
who are sneezing or coughing.
/In the event your child DOES become ill over
the next few months, then there’s probably
no reason to worry.
But if they start exhibiting respiratory problems
or showing signs of extreme muscle weakness
- then, the CDC says, you should contact a
doctor immediately.
/Of course the silver lining here, and the
one thing you SHOULD remember if your child
does get sick, is that enterovirus, usually
isn’t deadly.
Which means the case of the boy in New Jersey,
appears to be an extreme outlier.
What do you guys think about this?
And are you more worried about enterovirus,
or Ebola?
Let us know your answers in the comments below
- and as always, thanks for watching!